oi eu sou de amb e aí olha que esse
campeonato bom vocês olha eu vou
disputar aqui comigo está tudo bem vamos
mostrar agora o maior empreendimento
desse canal vem comigo se divertir e
montam o que é isso isso isso é um
cérebro que é isso e disse é um robô que
você construiu para dominar o mundo
claro que não que nem todos vocês aqui
um ventilador digo que eu estava linda
como bom dormir foi levantado caruaru
deus perde-se vinculador não sei como
decepou meu deus agora é que eu vou
mostrar surpreso na afetação caro
ventilado de gestão é que só pra mim é
ostentação e caco dólares graças à arte
e eu fui assistir um filme é um filme de
romance meu deus não é assim eu gosto de
filme romance e eu assistir filme de
romance para sua mãe eu confesso a vocês
que eu não sou um et derramar eu sou o
chão leite ramo nunca eu sempre intenção
não chorar mais adiante
[Música]
já está assistindo aí é titanic se
iniciou já passamos enquanto vêem na
globo onde foi maldade vez já passou
chave no sbt opina rebolo da otan
investiga passou de tanta água
é muito emocionante e cuida fica chora o
meu deus a nova sede do filme o papel
dessa cena que eu já acredito que vá
acontecer
a menina está em cima da porta aí eu
quero um carro em cima aí ele fica lá
esperando é o tapa na cabeça pode
acontecer alguma coisa
paul de obra na cabeça e morreu em
questão não sabe que seja assim
[Música]
acho muito estranho filme romance é
porque o filme de romance é mais ou
menos assim a menina é negada nerd da
escola se apaixona pelo cara que é todos
maioral todos líder da turma de basquete
joga beisebol joga futebol handebol
tênis basquete tudo mesmo tempo ele é
forte bonito e elegante na street aí
qualquer história a menina feia e nerds
se apaixona pelo cara que é tudo e
bonito cara só que tem um erro nessa
história a menina feia do filme é mais
bonito do que todas as meninas bonitas
da minha escola juntas ao me leva pra
isso nessa escola cahê quando o menino
que se apaixona e sempre se apaixona pra
mim que a líder de torcida e aí cara dói
quando eu jogava na minha escola não
tinha nem torcida veja lá um líder ou
continuação do filme romance que sempre
aquela cena da menina em câmera lenta
sabe
i e ii eip porque está em câmera lenta
desse jeito aí
[Música]
i e ii já bem isso ele inicia bem que eu
acho que está furada
[Música]
não não tô doido foi doído 82 donated de
pensar daqui ficarem gostei nada
o dono do bar não gostei para nós se a
primeira vez está assistindo um vídeo
meu canal clique aqui embaixo inscrever
se você se inscreve no canal não vai
perder mais nenhum vídeo canal e toda
vez que tiver vida ou se é saber por que
você comece aqui embaixo que você acha
mais engraçado é que as mais estranhas
filme de romance
lembrando que o primeiro na descrição do
vídeo da loja k no ila tem um monte de
coisa para vender tem skate e bicicleta
tem tênis tem de roupa e tem tudo e se
você comprar por este link na descrição
do vídeo você tem os descontos lá porque
você está em torno de ronaldo viola
moral do nordeste moral ponho tudo muito
essa [ __ ] em baixa umidade à noite o
meu twitter pra você me seguir o meu
facebook e tem também o que tem
o instagram é lógico então aí vai poder
assistir esse vídeo e iêmen